[MUSIC PLAYING]
SRIRAM KARRA: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to this talk on
security keys and anti-phishing.
My name is Sriram Karra.
I'm a product manager in
enterprise authentication
and security.
And I have my colleague
here, Christiaan Brand,
who is also in Google Cloud.
So today, we're
going to be talking
about authentication and
security keys, in particular.
So here is the agenda
in front of us.
We'll start with a brief
refresher on why passwords
basically suck, what
are the MFA options we
have at Google with a specific
focus on security keys.
And we're going to be doing
a deep dive into a product
announcement we
made earlier today,
an exciting new feature where
you can use your phone as a U2F
security key.
And then, if all
goes to plan, we
will have some
time left for Q&A.
Talking of Q&A, we'd like you to
try out this new feature called
Dory Q&A, which you can access
through the Cloud Next app.
If you can find our session,
you will find a link
below the session description to
Dory Q&A. The thing about Dory
is you can ask questions
anytime in the app.
And then you can also see what
questions others are asking,
and you can vote on them.
And so if there are
a lot of questions,
we will start with the
ones that are most popular
and work our way downwards.
We also have two mics.
We will come to them.
If that's your preferred
way to ask questions,
you can always do that.
Now, with that, let's get
started with passwords.
So what's wrong with passwords?
For starters, weak
passwords are everywhere.
In 2015, a study based on the
Verizon data breach analysis
showed that these are the two
most popular passwords that
were found in that breach.
The thing is, three years later,
in 2018, when the same analysis
was done based on more
updated data breaches,
the situation is still the same.
I don't know how
many of you noticed,
but the date on the slide,
it changed from 2015 to 2018.
Now, the way
organizations typically
deal with these weak passwords
is by enforcing complexity
rules and composition rules.
Essentially all of
us have seen them.
Passwords should require one
uppercase, one lowercase, one
number, and so on and so forth.
The problem with these
composition rules,
firstly, is that it's
a pain for users.
Users are super frustrated.
If you don't trust me,
just look at how frustrated
that user looks.
The other part about
these complexity rules
is they don't even work.
Research has shown that when
you have hardwired composition
rules like this, users
deal with them in extremely
predictable ways, like they
replace A with the @ symbol,
they add an exclamation mark at
the end of the word, and so on.
So there are very
predictable ways
in which users to deal with
these composition rules.
And so they don't really
add anything significant
in terms of
security, but it just
adds frustration for users.
So right now, the
security best practices
is to take away the
burden from the users
and offload the burden
onto the services
so that service providers
like Google and others
can enforce what are
strong passwords based
on current understanding
of security
best practices,
comparing passwords
with password breach databases,
and so on and so forth.
Now, even if you have overcome
the weak password problem
using security best
practices, a strong password
is no good if it is stolen.
And passwords are
stolen all the time.
So based on our research,
here are the top three ways
in which passwords are stolen.
No surprise there.
Data breaches of
third-party services,
malware that log your passwords
as they're being typed
and exfiltrate them,
and the big one--
phishing.
The reason I said phishing
is the big one compared
to the other ones is
also going back to--
is based on some research
we did a few years ago
when we keep updating
that research.
We looked at a user who was
prone to a phishing attack.
And let's say the credential
was compromised in the phishing
attack.
And we compared the likelihood
of such users getting
compromised completely,
that is, they
are losing access
to their account as
compared to a randomly-selected
Gmail account.
So the hijacking likelihood of
a phished user was 500 times
a normal user, or
randomly selected user.
This likelihood is
significantly lower
for other forms of
credential compromise.
And in particular, you can
see if your password was found
in a breach, it's
only 10 times worse,
whereas if you were phished,
it is 500 times worse.
The reason for this difference
is also interesting.
This is just one example
of why or one reason
why there's a significant
difference between them.
It is because, as
a service provider,
we can provide
certain protections
against leaked passwords that
don't apply in the phishing
case.
This is part of that same
program we did a few years ago.
We found compromised credentials
from various breaches.
We found a certain
number of them
were actually valid passwords
for their Gmail accounts,
and we were immediately able
to lock those accounts down.
Now, this kind of a thing,
it is a batch process.
It's not possible in a phishing
attack where, by the time
we come to know if it,
it's probably too late.
Phishing is also becoming more
important relative to malware.
It is becoming more and more
possible because of automated
phishing kits that are available
that even phish multifactor,
as we will see in a moment.
And malware is becoming
harder to write,
and phishing is just
brutally effective.
So phishing is just-- there
are just more phishing
sites and more phishing
kits available now as
compared to malware.
So it's not all
bad news, though.
The good news here
is, at Google,
even if a malicious actor
has a username and password,
in 99.9% of the cases, Google
is able to do some risk analysis
based on geographical location,
device security, history,
and so on, and block 99% of
those malicious accesses.
But the 0.1% are also important.
So the answer for
those 0.1% typically
has been multi-factor
authentication.
Now, multi-factor
authentication methods,
many of them are available--
SMS, TOTP, mobile push,
and so on and so forth.
But many of them have
their own problems.
Usability is one of them.
Phishability is the bigger of
the two, because in some sense,
an OTP is also something
that a user knows.
It's not a long-lived
knowledge, but it's
a short-lived
knowledge that you just
learned maybe a minute ago.
And it can be phished
in exactly the same way
that the primary
factor can be phished.
So the OTPs and most the
traditional MFA methods
are not really the solution
to all of the problems.
So the right way
to think about MFA
is that it provides a
spectrum of assurance.
MFA methods are
not all the same.
So here's what we
would recommend.
Any MFA is better than no MFA.
That's number one.
The second part of it is, of
all the available methods,
if you put them on a scale,
SMS and voice-based codes
are the least secure
of these methods
because not only
are they phishable,
but they also have
other problems
that are now well known,
which include [? SSM ?]
vulnerabilities, carrier social
engineering attacks, and so on.
So it's widely now
known that SMS is
the weakest of all of the lot.
But it's still
better than nothing.
The second bucket
of MFA methods,
we have all the other codes.
We have backup codes,
Google authenticated
or TOTP-based apps, and
then mobile push methods
such as Google prompt.
These don't have all
of the problems of SMS.
But still, all these
three can be phished.
And increasingly we're finding
phishing attacks or phishing
kits that make it
very easy for these
to be phished in real time.
So the answer to
this phishing problem
essentially is hardware
FIDO security keys.
And these are the
only MFA method
that have been designed to
be resistant to phishing
from the ground up.
So to talk more
about FIDO, I'm going
to call Christiaan to
come up to the stage.
CHRISTIAAN BRAND: Hi, folks.
I'm Christiaan.
And I'm a product
manager at Google
working on strong authentication
and security keys.
So I want to tell
you a little bit more
about what we do at Google to
prevent phishing, or at least
try and curb it.
We've had these security keys
in use on Google accounts
for the better part
of three, four years.
And we've even made a
statement last year--
I believe it was during Next--
where we said that no Google
account has successfully been
phished or at least Googler--
Google stuff-- has
essentially been
phished since we've deployed the
security key technology, which
is really the primary
purpose of this.
The core issue, really,
that users are struggling
with nowadays when
authenticating
is that they arrive at a website
and enter their credentials,
but they have no way of knowing
that that website is really
the correct, legitimate website
that they're interacting with.
Yes, there is TLS certificates
that you can go and validate.
There are telltale
signs, hopefully,
in the URL address bar.
But these things are tricky.
And if you go by the security
zone down on the show floor,
we have two laptops set
up next to each other.
One is at a phishing website,
and the other one is not.
And it's very,
very hard to tell.
It just is.
Most of us here
at the conference
are security professionals,
and even for us,
it is tricky, especially if
that's not the only thing
that we want to do
on that web page.
It's not all about
validating URLs for us.
We actually want to
get the job done.
We want to send an email.
We want to log in.
We want to get access to a file.
So we're not spending that much
time checking URLs every day.
And that really is kind of
the primary problem here.
And security keys are
meant to address that.
We specifically developed
the security key technology,
together with industry, to
solve and address that problem.
And the way that that works is--
there we go.
The way that that works
is the security key
basically communicates
locally to the hosts.
In other words, you plug it in.
There is information
being sent from the host
to the security key.
It does validation also based on
the origin, like where you are,
where you're browsing to.
And it will not release
the signatures, as you say,
until it recognizes that
it's on the correct website
that it wants to interact with.
And we'll look at that in
a little bit more detail
here in a couple of slides.
So very, very simple--
if you're on the correct
URL, the security key works.
If not, it doesn't.
Pretty straightforward.
It's created with open
standards, as I said earlier.
We work in two standards bodies,
in standards organizations.
The one is in the W3C--
World Wide Web Consortium.
And recently, we reached
W3C recommendation status.
That means, usually, that
web browsers look at what
the W3C is coming up with.
Typically, also, are involved
in the standardization process.
And they usually
pick up standards
that reach recommended status
recommendation in the W3C.
And that is why we've seen folks
like Edge, Mozilla Firefox,
of course Chrome, as well
as Safari in Tech Preview
actually take this seriously
and start doing implementation.
We've recently moved over,
I guess, about three,
four weeks ago, in anticipation
of the launch today, which
I'll show a demo about.
We've moved over to the W3C
standard, as opposed to what
we were doing before, which was
kind of like a pre-fully W3C
rectified standard called
U2F, which is basically
the protocol
between a web server
and your logged-in device.
So if you were a
website and you want
to implement this
cool new stuff here,
you need to understand
the W3C WebAuthn protocol.
There is another
protocol involved here,
which is called CTAP, the Client
To Authenticator Protocol.
That is still being
standardized in FIDO.
But a lot less, I guess,
folks in the world
really need to know
about that protocol.
That's the one that your device,
your browser, your platform
needs to communicate
to the security key.
One way to communicate
is using USB.
There's a standardized
framing and a format
for doing this communication.
If you are interested
in developing
security keys,
then, of course, you
need to understand
that protocol.
But if you're a web developer
and you want implement this
on your website, you
absolutely don't.
You only need to
understand WebAuthn.
If you want to make
security keys, of course,
it's an open standard.
Anyone can participate.
Anyone can make a security key.
And Google, as folks
know, will pretty much
accept any security
key from any vendor.
As long as you adhere
to the standards,
that key will work
on Google properties.
So we'll talk a little bit more
about that particular protocol
here in a second.
But the important
thing here is, this
is mediated by Chrome or by
your browser or your platform
on your machine--
this communication.
And then it goes over
either USB, NFC--
Near-Field Communication--
or Bluetooth Low Energy.
Those are the three standardized
transports on that level.
So that's kind of like
if you were interested
how Fido and W3C both
fit into this process,
a little bit of both in there.
Last year at Next, we introduced
the Titan Security Key.
It is one more option.
There are security keys out
there from many vendors.
Anyone can make
security keys that
behaves according
to the standard
and works with property
supporting WebAuthn or security
keys.
But we wanted to introduce one
more option, one option that
basically has a little bit
of Google goodness in there.
And that's what we did in
the Titan Security Key.
Essentially, as we said, it's
a phishing-resistant second
factor.
We've said that
a bunch of times.
But more importantly, it
includes a secure element
with firmware that was written
by Google, which you can then
use, and gives you
this that little bit
of extra goodness in there.
It's an open ecosystem.
The key will work
with any other website
that understands WebAuthn.
And there's many of these
different websites out there
today.
Here's a more detailed slide on
how the security key actually
works when you're
trying to log in.
So I'll go through this.
And if there's
questions at the end,
we can delve in a
little bit deeper.
But I do think it's important
to at least understand
this at the superficial level.
So this gets one
level below just
understanding that
there's coms happening
between these devices.
So how this works is, when I
try to log into www.google.com,
of course, my phone will send
that request to the server.
And the very next
thing the server
will do once I've entered
my username and my password,
the server will generate
a cryptographic challenge.
Now, in this example,
we assume that the user
will have already
registered their security
key with their Google
account at some point in time
before this happens.
The registration is very simple.
The key generates a unique
public-private key key pair.
It gives the public
key to the service--
Google, in this
case-- and Google
will store that against
this particular account.
So Alice, in this example,
is trying to sign in.
And Google knows that there is
a particular public key that
belongs to Alice on file
at the server at Google.
And we send a cryptographic
challenge, basically,
for freshness, right?
We say, here are
some random data.
You're going to need to
do something with that.
We just pass that along.
So the random data
is passed along
to the client-- in
this case, the phone.
The very next thing
that happens is,
Chrome looks at, or the browser
looks at the URL bar or the web
origin, and sees, ah,
this is for Google.com.
OK, that's cool.
So we're going to remember that.
And then we're going to
send that information
on over the CTAP protocol.
Remember, everything happening
on the left side of the picture
is W3C WebAuthn.
On the right side
of the picture,
that communication is
happening via CTAP.
So we're going to send this
information from the browser
to the security key
over USB, in this case.
And we're going to include the
challenge that the server sent.
But we're also
going to include--
kind of like the caller ID.
Like, who is the actual property
asking for the signature?
We'll look at the URL bar.
We'll strip that out,
and we'll send that along
over the USB protocol,
to the security key.
Security key will then generate
a cryptographic signature.
So basically, it
takes a challenge.
It signs it using
the private key
that it generated
over a year ago
or whenever we
registered the key.
It generates this signature.
And it sends the
signature all the way back
via the USB protocol and via
WebAuthn all the way back
to the server.
The server looks at this, sees
that the challenge that it sent
is correct.
It is signed by the private key
that the security key knows.
The server doesn't know
the private key, though.
The server only
knows the public key.
But using public-private
cryptography
or public-private
key cryptography.
It can verify that the key
knows the correct secret
without ever exposing that
secret to the server itself.
How great is that
for data breaches?
If something happens
with the server nowadays,
your passwords are exposed.
We can run through.
It doesn't matter if the
password is hashed or whatever.
Like rainbow tables and
other stuff are out there,
passwords get cracked.
Because of the fact that we
use symmetric authentication
on the web today, your
password's going to be cracked.
In this example,
even if someone--
if there is a data breach
over at the server side
and things get compromised, yes,
they'll have your user name.
They'll have your password.
But they will never
have your private key,
because that private key is
never stored on the server.
The public key is
stored on the server.
That allows the server
to know that you
have the right security key.
But it never allows the
server to impersonate
that said security key, which
is really cool, really nifty.
The other thing, of course,
here is that we sign.
We don't only sign
the challenge.
We also sign the web origin.
So the server is
absolutely certain
that you are looking
at the correct website
at the point in time when the
security key was presented.
So both of these two
things are signed together,
both the challenge
and the web origin.
And that all get sent
down to the server.
The user is looking at
the incorrect website,
the incorrect thing
will be signed,
and the server will
simply reject it.
So pretty straightforward.
And we'll look at
something else here
in more detail in a second.
So what we're really here is
talk about-- and at this point,
it's kind of old news.
We've said it from this
morning or this keynote,
and then we revealed it in the
security spotlight session.
We wanted to make things
a little easier for users.
It's great to have multiple
options in security keys--
NFC, USB, maybe a Bluetooth
key that I can use.
But it's still an
additional device
that I have to carry around.
How cool would it
be if the thing
that's already in my pocket--
my mobile phone-- could
just be my security key
for my Google account?
Now, we're going to say,
well, that's not new.
I've been using my phone
to authenticate for years.
Well, that's true.
It started out with using SMS
as a one-time password sent
to a phone.
Then we started looking at
authenticator applications
running on the phone,
generating one-time passwords.
Even push authentication
nowadays, you get a message
and you say yes.
The technology that you're
going to look at right
now is very similar in
the user experience.
You also look at the phone
and say yes to a message.
The critical difference
is, that message is not
going via the cloud.
There is some slides
in here later where
we break that whole
log-in process down
and where we see the
difference between
traditional push-based
authentication
and this technology here.
Because there is
a local proximity
channel between the laptop
and my mobile phone,
we can apply the
same protocol which
makes sure the user is
looking at the right website
at the point in time when
they're trying to sign in.
That really is the
breakthrough here--
very, very, very simple concept.
But obviously,
the implementation
is hard because you have
to deal with Bluetooth
and different browsers
and different platforms.
But in the end, all
these things make up
a cohesive whole, which
gives you a user experience
that users are used to.
They've been doing it for years.
But this time, really giving
them that elevated threat
protection, the
phishing protection
that security keys and the
protocol have pulled in.
So pretty straightforward.
And then there's one last
thing here which we'll
talk about a little bit later.
If you happen to have
a Pixel 3, last year,
when we announced
the Pixel 3, we also
mentioned that the Pixel 3
has a Titan M chip in there.
So there's a cryptographic
secure element built by Google
that does a bunch of things.
In that blog post at the
time, we alluded to the fact
that, hey, maybe
later this thing
can also be used
as a security key.
And I guess that time is now.
So on a Pixel 3, we're actually
using and storing your FIDO key
material-- the
cryptographic material
that we use to generate
these signatures-- directly
in that secure element.
And the secure element
actually happens
to be hard-wired
through the volume
down button on my
Pixel phone, which
is why I have to press that
button during authentication
on this particular device, which
means if there is something
else running on the phone, it'll
never be able to physically
press the butto, which is
kind of the same premise
with security keys.
That's why we require a button
press at the point in time
when we're going
to do signature.
Even if there's something
else, maybe malicious, running,
it hopefully will not be
able to physically exercise
my security key's button.
But we'll talk about that.
So let's now jump into a demo.
So what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to ask folks to switch over
to the laptop right here.
And I'll bring up the
phone here in a second.
But let's start-- this is a
user who's signed into Gmail.
Let's refresh and make
sure everything looks good.
Cool.
I already use security keys.
And this is the state that
we want users to be in.
We really want users setting up
their phone's built-in security
key to already have
something else that they
can use if this process fails.
That's why we're saying beta--
not because of the
technology, necessarily,
having an inherent problem,
but you need Bluetooth for this
to work.
And you're not always going
to be on a machine that
has Bluetooth.
You have a desktop.
If you sign in on
unsupported platform,
let's say like Windows versions
older than Windows 10--
younger? older than
Windows 10?, so lower--
you might have a
private challenge.
So the protocol right
now is supported
on pretty much all Android
7-plus phones and Windows 10,
Chrome OS, and Mac OS.
But again, Bluetooth
is a requirement.
So we want you to have a backup.
So this user is in
that perfect state.
If I click on my account
details over here, and I
review my security settings.
You will see, under
two-step verification,
that this user has a couple of
security keys already setup.
So this user happens to
have a Titan USB key--
one right here-- and a
Titan Bluetooth key--
this one right here.
So these things are already
set up on the account.
Today, we see this
promo happening.
And the promo says,
hey, by the way,
you have a compatible Android
phone already on your account.
The way we know this
is, this user already
signed into their Android
device using this Google
account at some previous time.
So we were able to
correlate this and say, hey,
we think you have a compatible
phone for this technology.
This promo might
take a little while
to show up for your account.
However, if you just click
the Add Security Key button,
you should immediately be
able to use this technology.
That was already
released this morning.
So if you click
Add Security Key,
which I will do in
this case, you'll
see all your various options.
If you don't have
any eligible phones,
it'll go straight into the, hey,
add a USB or Bluetooth security
key.
In this case, I happen to
have a compatible Pixel
3 on my account.
If you have more than one
phone, they'll all show up here
and you can pick
what you want to use.
I've got my Pixel 3,
at this point, which
is what I'm going to activate.
Going to click it.
It will tell me a
bunch of like things
like I need Bluetooth
at the location,
other things on the phone
from this technology to work.
Don't need pairing.
That's the critical part here.
With these other Bluetooth keys
that we spoke about earlier,
we needed pairing.
You would need to pair
this device with our phone
or with our laptop
for it to work.
We listened to our users,
and they don't like pairing.
It's hard.
If you've ever tried to pair
a phone and a laptop together,
it's not easy.
We wanted to get away from that.
So we said, what can we do
to make the protocol easier?
So we basically came up
with a little extension
to the WebAuthn protocol
that's standardized right now.
And this extension
allows for pairing
less-secure communication
between your laptop
and your phone.
The protocol extension is being
standardized in the standards
organization FIDO as we speak.
It has not completely
been ratified yet.
It takes a while.
We've decided, as Chrome, to
do the first implementation.
Any other browser, of course,
is free to do the same thing.
But we wanted to
get it out there
so we can start testing with
this particular protocol.
So we expect other browsers
to pick it up right now,
or at some point, too.
But right now, Chrome
is the browser where
this protocol is implemented.
So anyway, we'll Add.
In the end, it'll say,
hey, everything's cool.
So I'll go back.
And now I see three
security keys on my account.
I've got my Google Pixel 3.
I've got my USB key.
And I have my Bluetooth key.
So now, let's see how
this works during sign-in.
So I will close this window.
I will open a new
incognito window.
And at this point, I'm
going to try and display
my Pixel 3 on this screen.
So let's move that
out of the way.
So this is my phone
that I have here.
And I'm going to try
and access Gmail.
So Gmail.com.
I am going to enter my
demo account credentials.
And at this point
in time, I should
see the new UI
appearing, which tells me
I can use either USB or
Bluetooth, of course.
But I'm going to
pick to use my phone.
That's the default if you
have a phone on your account.
And we see a message pop up.
This is a Pixel 3
experience which
says I have to hold
down the Volume
Down button, which
I'm going to do.
Going to click it and hold it
down until the blue checkmark
appears.
Going to be a local Bluetooth
connectivity between these two
devices.
And once that completes,
I will be allowed
to sign in to my account.
And at this point, it
did all of those checks
that we spoke about earlier.
There were challenges passed.
The phone signed it.
The key material happened to
be stored in the Titan M chip.
Crypto happened there.
And we also made
sure on the way back
that I was actually looking
at the legitimate website
here, the real
mail.google.com and not
some other, malicious
website, perhaps.
So anyways, so that's the demo.
So we'll go back to the
slide deck, at this point,
and we'll see what
happened there.
So how this fit
in-- same picture.
I'm just going to go through
it really quickly because we
really discussed this already.
And the point of
this picture is just
to show it's exactly
the same technology
and the same protocol
that we've been using,
like with USB and physical
Bluetooth security
keys in place here.
Same thing.
We're sending data over.
It can be sent via
other USB, NFC, or BLE.
And at this point,
it will send via BLE.
And phone signed it,
sent it all the way back.
And the server
validated that this
was the correct key-- well,
the correct secret that signed
this cryptographic challenge.
So pretty straightforward.
I don't have to go
into this too much.
Of course, it offers a stronger
defense against phishing.
That's the point
we're trying to make.
And it very verifies user's
identity and the URL or the URL
that you're visiting.
This is kind of
the takeaway slide.
If there's two things
that you remember
from this presentation, this
is what security keys do.
It's about the protocol.
It's not about the
physical form factor.
Ever since we started on
the path of security keys,
the intent was always to
bring the thing in your pocket
to be that technology
that you can
use without having to
make the user carry around
something else.
Of course, security
keys has its place.
You still use that to
bootstrap an account,
have that as your backup.
But you now have one
additional option.
It's just technologically much
easier to make these devices
than implement everything
directly on the device itself,
inside the phone.
So as one of the
last sections here,
I want to just show
the difference between
the nonsecurity key, push-based
authentication protocol
and the push-based
authentic-- or, sorry,
and the BLE-based
authentication protocol,
right So for the push-based
the one that goes via
the cloud normally that--
we offer it as Google.
The name that we call
it is Google Prompt.
So you can activate
Google Prompt.
You could set that up as
your 2SV mechanism for ages.
We actually changed it
over a couple of months,
maybe a year ago so
that you can set that up
as your default option.
So if you activate two-step
verification or multifactor
authentication on a
Google account today,
Google Prompt is the option
that you're going to get.
It's great.
It's very like straightforward.
It has the same user
experience roughly
as what we've seen here.
But it sends the
messages via the cloud.
So if you look at what's going
on on this diagram right here,
this is how users get tricked.
User goes, and the
user goes to a website.
At this point, I
call it phishing.com,
but it's a little bit more
subtle than that in real life.
I end up going to a website
that looks a lot like Google.
But it's not really the
real Google website.
What's, in essence,
happening is,
I'm visiting a website that's
proxying all of my information
and all of the data between
the real Google and me.
So that's what we're seeing.
In step 3, that's Google.
That's the real Google servers.
However, I'm not
interacting with it.
I'm interacting with something
that is interacting with it.
So they're proxying
everything back to my machine
and to my browser.
So what's happening is,
user is interacting.
They're typing in
their username.
Bad guy's getting it.
They're typing in
their password.
Bad guy's getting it.
They're sending it on
to the real Google.
Real Google happily
sends the push message
to the real user, who is trying
to sign in at this point.
But of course, when I
say yes to that message,
I'm not signing me in.
I'm signing the bad guy in.
And there's no way for Google
to know whether they're
interacting with
the legitimate user
or with someone proxying
everything on the user's
behalf.
And that's really the problem,
and one of the reasons
why these push messages
contain other metadata.
It says things like the location
you're trying to sign in from.
So you might be like,
why's it telling me
where I'm signing in from?
I know where I'm
signing in from.
Well, it's because if someone
is proxying that message,
hopefully, they're not in
the same location as you.
And you'll check that
message and see, oh,
this guy's trying to sign
it from a different country
or a different state.
I'm clearly going to
say no to this message.
Using IPG location,
mostly, so nowadays, it's
very easy for folks to
set up VPN tunnels that
pop out in roughly the
same neighborhood or areas
that you're in.
So that's another challenge.
There is a way to circumvent
some of these technologies.
Other push authentication
technologies
show you the IP address
of who you're seeing.
Who knows what their IP is
when they're trying to sign in?
You're not going to
go and check out,
what is my
public-facing IP address
every time you do one
of these messages.
So even that kind of stuff
doesn't really, really work.
Sure, we're putting
more of the burden
back to the user where they
can potentially figure out
whether they're interacting
with a legitimate site or not.
But it's not that easy to tell.
We wanted to solve that problem.
We wanted to say,
well, why don't we
make it the technology's problem
and not the user's problem?
And that's really
where we ended up here.
Much simpler picture, right?
The user is now looking
at the phishing website.
Bad guy is still up
there to the left.
But this time around,
because the communication
to the mobile phone is directly
from the user's machine
to the phone and not, as
in the previous picture,
from the Google
Cloud to the phone,
we're able to tell
the phone the URL
that the user is looking at.
And the phone will either
refuse to sign the message,
or we'll sign it but we'll send
back the data to the cloud.
In this case, what
we're seeing is,
the browser is sending back
phishing.com in that signature,
and Google is going,
no, no, no, no.
That's not the website
the user should be looking
at when they're logging in.
So really, really
straightforward
if you think about
the technology.
Again, really, critically
important, but very,
very simple.
And that's how-- or
at least a difference
between using traditional
push-based mechanisms, which,
again, there's nothing
wrong with it, inherently.
It's certainly better than
not having any 2SV2 at all,
and certainly better than
some other 2SV options.
But if you want
this enhanced level
of protection--
in the early days,
you had to get one of these.
Now you have one
more option in just
turning your phone into it.
So the prompt on the phone
looks very much the same.
If you don't happen to
have a Pixel 3 device,
the prompt actually
looks pretty much
exactly the same as the
Google Prompt technology.
If you look at that
screen there on the right
and you look at the one here,
it is very much similar.
We don't show you any of
the other stuff anymore.
We don't show you the
location or the IP address
or anything like that,
because at this point,
it's not important.
We know these things are local.
That's the important part.
So to end off and wrap
up here, it's convenient.
Users are prompted to verify
their sign-in on their phone.
It's pretty straightforward.
There is a one-time,
simple enrollment.
We've seen that.
It's pretty straightforward.
You don't need to install
any apps on the phone.
You don't even need to upgrade
the software of your Android
phone.
It happens automatically
in the background.
Your phone should have
it, at this point.
All Android 7-plus
devices should have this.
And the way that we technically
get this to the phone
is an integration with something
called Google Play Services,
which is like a
back-end component that
lives in Android
phones that interact
with Google properties.
So if you have access to
Gmail and other services
on the device, typically, this
module is already present.
And it's constantly
updating in the background.
And that's what we're
using to deliver
this functionality to devices,
going back a couple of years.
Right now, it's available
to more than 50%.
If you look at the distribution
of Android devices,
more than 50% of
users running 7-plus.
So available to more than
50% of the Android market.
And it's free.
You don't have to
pay anything for it.
You can just enable it.
The only thing you need
is a compatible device.
And as I said earlier,
there's one more thing here,
which is, if you happen to
have a Pixel 3 device which
has the Titan M
chip built into it,
we will actually be using
very much the same way that we
differentiate regular security
keys versus Titan security
keys.
It's kind of the same
way that we differentiate
the built-in security
key on Android
versus the built-in security
key on Android Pixel 3.
Kind of the same thing.
It's just a little
bit more trust
in where those keys
are actually stored
and in the way that
you exercise it.
Again, I don't want to
go into too much detail
on the differences here and
say that one is necessarily
better than the other.
Remember, the attack we're
trying to prevent against here
is remote phishing.
We're trying to prevent someone
that's in a different country
or in a different
location than you
trying to sign
in, because that's
the threat that's scalable.
That's the thing that
we see on the web.
That's also the stuff that you
saw Sriram speak about earlier.
If we look at the
amount of phishing
websites that's springing up
every month, it's staggering.
That's the type of thing
we want to protect against.
And for that, it doesn't really
matter where on your phone
the key is stored.
It can be stored on file
system or in a [? TEE, ?]
or even in the Titan M chip.
It doesn't really
matter that much.
But we do have this
additional level
of protection, the same as with
the physical Titan security
key for folks who
care about that.
Last slide, here.
It's available now
in beta, as we said.
It's available on
Android 7 phones,
works with
Bluetooth-enabled Chrome
browser on Chrome OS,
Mac OS X, and Windows 10.
And you can use it both on
your personal Gmail account
as well as on any of
our enterprise accounts.
And if an administrator
has set up an organization
to require a security key, this
is now a valid way to, I guess,
address that particular
constraint, where
you can set up your
phone, and it'll happily
satisfy the constraint of using
a security key on that account.
[MUSIC PLAYING]